lucratif ont choisi de ne pas
attendre et décident d'acheter
des terrains privés dans
l'objectif de les protéger à
perpétuité.
- Donc ici, à notre gauche..
L'L'L'archipel des îles de
Varennes abrite de nombreuses
espèces d'oiseaux et de
poissons. Matthew Chapman
y navigue fréquemment. En 2020,
lui et sa conjointe ont acheté
une île de 4 hectares.
- Donc, là bas, c'est
l'île à la Truie?
- Exact.
- L'île se trouve à moins
de 2 kilomètres des rives
de Montréal et de Varennes.
MATTHEW CHAPMAN,
propriétaire de l'île à la Truie
- On a trouvé l'île à vendre
sur Kijiji et on l'a achetée
à 50 000. À peu près la moitié
de l'île est inondable. Donc,
on n'a pas le droit, selon les
règlements, de construire quoi
que ce soit de permanent sur
l'île. D'ici 20 ans, en fait,
l'objectif, c'est de donner
l'île à un organisme qui va...
qui va en prendre soin.
- Acquérir des terrains privés
pour les protéger à perpétuité,
c'est aussi la mission de plus
de 70 organismes au Québec.
Dans les Laurentides, le Comité
régional pour la protectio
falaises s'affaire à protéger
un territoire de 16 kilomètres
carrés abritant une faune
et une flore fragile
GILBERT TOUSIGNANT, comité rég.
pour la protection des falaises
- Les premiers bénévoles qui
ont voulu trav à à à à protéger
ce territoire-là espéraient
que ce soit les municipalités
ou soit le gouvernement du
Québec qnnnnnnnnent la relève.
On s'est rendu compte à la
longue que ça se produirait pas.
Alors, c'est là qu'on a décidé
-mê-mê-mê-mê-mêmes de se mettre
à protéger des terrains,
par acquisition ou par don.
- L'organisme a acquis depuis11t
200 hectares, à l'aide de fonds
gouvernementaux, de fonds privés
et de contributions volontaires.
Au Québec, près de 70 000
hectares de terrains privés
sont désormais protégés
de cette manière.
BRICE CAILLIÉ, dg, Réseau
des milieux naturels protégés
- Les outils du gouvernement
pour protéger le territoire
sont très difficile à mettre en
oeuvre dans les terres pri
parce qu'il faut discuter avec
chaque propriétaire. Donc,
le travail des organismes de
conservation, il va vraiment
être très complémentaire
à ce qui peut être fait
par le gouvernement.
- Et ces terrains doivent
répndre à certains critères.
- Il faut justifier la valeur
écologique de la propriété
et aussi, vu qu'on utilise de
l'argent public pour acheter ces
terrains, bien, il faut que le
l'acquisition se fasse à un coût
raisonnable, qu'on appelle en
fait la juste valeur marchande.
- Entre ville et nature,
Matthew Chapman cherche surtout
à éveiller les consciences.
- Pour moi, ce projet-ci,
c'est local, oui, mais c'est
aussi plus grand que ça.
J'aimerais que ça inspire
d'autres personnes à acheter
des terrains, puis les
préserver, les protéger.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-C